on a toujours une espèce de rubalise
pour délimiter pour éviter que tout le
monde se balade sur la scène analyser
une scène de crime
relevé des empreintes loin de l'image
véhiculée par les séries télé emmanuel
montre la réalité quotidienne de la
police scientifique et de faire ce qu'on
appelle des recherches de traces
donc en général de toi fouda des ailes
au niveau des vols par effraction des
petits cambriole souvent des jeunes sont
attirés par ce qu'ils pensent qu'on peut
faire et du terrain trouvé tout de suite
des scènes assez impressionnant tout ça
va amener de la loire et interroger les
suspects c'est ce qui n'est pas du tout
le cas de notre métier nous aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment segmenté il ya des
personnes qui vont faire des
prélèvements des personnes qui vont
faire les analyses et des personnes qui
vont faire l'anc est un forum pour
découvrir et comprendre les métiers liés
à la sécurité
lycéens et collégiens se sont rendus à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines pour s'informer je suis au gsp
depuis deux ans déjà et je voulais
m'orienter plus tard pour savoir comment
faire pour être touchés professionnelle
dans l'armée on a convié une trentaine
de professionnels qu'on peut rencontrer
aujourd'hui issus de dix corps de métier
donc on est parti quand même du besoin
de deux de ces corps de métiers des
services pénitentiaires et la police
nationale qui est
nous ont contactés pour nous faire part
de leurs difficultés de recrutement
cette année la police nationale espère
recruter 1000 jeunes sans condition de
diplôme en france plus de 3000 gardiens
de la paix et 2000 surveillants
pénitentiaires sont recherchés